no definitivamente no el duque será
sepultado hoy en la bóveda real pero
posteriormente cuando la reina isabel
muera será
sepultado junto a la reina y otros
integrantes de la familia real en el
memorial de el rey jorge sexto la
familia el padre de la rey el padre de
la reina la madre y la princesa margaret
definitivamente será un funeral muy
distinto y ustedes pueden ver a mis
espaldas aquí afuera del castillo de
windsor miles de personas se han
congregado pero no tantas como
generalmente serían en un evento normal
como mencionaste treinta personas son
los invitados la reina a sus cuatro
hijos sus ocho nietos y unos familiares
muy cercanos veremos una imagen muy
poderosa y al mismo tiempo triste
la reina isabel posiblemente sentada
sola y guardando la distancia social
como hace parte de las reglas aquí en
inglaterra en medio de esta pandemia